good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Thursday
hope everyone's having a great the
Thursday speaking of great hey Jax how
you doing I'm doing great because it's
Thursday it's the latter half of the
week
we did it
also we have such an exciting sickening
announcement today that we tried not to
like tease two hardsecret project photo
shoot but we really could have and I'm
so excited because now we can share the
secret project share the photo shoot
that we were both on set for beefing
with each other last week are you guys
ready for it well if you're a patreon
you already know because that's the
benefit of being a patreon you get to
know all the secrets early but we've
been working on something so exciting
the toast holiday Spritz pack
look at this gorgeous girl if you're
watching on YouTube we are holding up
our first ever I think it's like
official collab with the toast even
though like it's our company the whole
thing is a collab right um we have just
launched uh today I think you guys if
you're patreon members a bunch of you
already got it but if you're listening
now you'll be able to purchase
relatively soon it is our toast holiday
pack so it is a brand new packaging
featuring your girl's hands well
actually let's be real we were not we
were we were hand models hands we were
open to nudity but we were not open to
putting our own hands on this box and
you know what for aesthetic reasons I
think it's best that we use some stock
image hands but it's a new holiday pack
that when you open you're obviously
gonna get eight stunning cans of our
four original flavors but you're also
going to get a little poem that was
written by Jax I can't take credit
because this is like where Jax shines
thank you
um should we read it
I feel like that kind of gives it away
but it's a really sweet Christmas poem
we could read the first line which is
Twas the night before toastmas
ooh spoiled like Cliffhanger what
happened next
had to spritzociety.com to find out so
not only this gives you two of each of
the amazing flavors of Spritz of the
original flavors but the packaging makes
it so that it's the perfect gift for
someone look it already has a little bow
right there in the corner so you don't
have to wrap it and for me that's those
are the kind of gifts I want to give
because I look like the kind of girl who
knows how to wrap a present but I
actually try as I may it looks terrible
every time and if you flip to the bottom
of the pack you're you're gonna get a
sickening QR code that looks like a a
record disc and why does it look like a
record disc because when you scan this
QR code you're going to be taken to the
toast holiday playlist full of some of
the best old and new holiday songs the
classics the trendy ones and it's just
very exciting to have our very own
packaging and we did this really cute
photo shoot with very holiday themed me
and Jax Ben was there dressed up as
Santa and we'll be shooting strikes
Brethren we're there the stripes
Brethren we'll be sure on our social
today and tomorrow there is Limited
stock and there aren't a ton so make
sure you go to Sprint society.com
patreon members you already know another
reason to be a patreon member
also the holiday playlist is amazing and
when you're enjoying your holiday
festivities this is the playlist that
you want to play but I love the idea of
having the playlist scannable on the box
because when you're drinking you don't
want to be like hey what's up what's
that playlist toast holiday playlist
it's like bam
bam
so this box really has everything it has
fun in a box it's got drinks it's
colorful it's pink and scented gives it
a little something extra don't you think
by the way just for legal disclaimer
it's not actually scented there that is
a quote from Legally Blonde oh yes sorry
legal I hope you've seen Legally Blonde
also facts that you might want to know
so if you buy two boxes if you get two
of the holiday packs you will get free
shipping 15 15 off plus free shipping if
you get three or more packs you get 25
off plus free shipping so that's just
something that I feel like everyone
needs to know it's buy more save more
events I was literally just gonna say
it's a buy more save more thing yeah
that's probably more savemore's know all
about it all about it so that's
spritzociety.com it's a limited launch
so once we're sold out that's it and so
this is just like a really fun moment in
time like you know how much we love the
holidays you know how much we love
Spritz we wanted to do something really
special for all of you and also make
partying really easy this year and gift
giving like that's what it's giving
gifts that's what we're about we are the
gift that keeps on giving ain't that the
truth the box has two grapefruit two
blood orange two pineapple and two lemon
it's really it's quite sickening
honestly quite and just make sure you're
following us on Instagram so you can see
these stunning photos we did from this
photo shoot it was so cute you guys and
also if you follow us on Instagram you
might also get like a teaser of the poem
honestly like I would get the box just
for the poem because you know what we
said yesterday poetry is more personal
than comedy more personal than food like
this poem is so personal to me and if
you ever thought like Jackie uh could
she be a poet what would she have to say
that box will tell you everything that's
in my heart she could
she could do it it's toast poetry it's
toaster tree
we should do more toast poetry should we
write a collection of poems slam poems I
love
yeah like I think we we would write okay
I love it okay ready we read a book of
poetry and then we would tour the
country doing slam poetry Live Events
and everyone our podcast tour will be
not like other podcasters We're not
gonna play games like it's going to be a
slam poetry podcast tour and people can
get up on stage and perhaps recite a
performance of their favorite toast
poetry song
I think this is so awesome honestly
bring back poetry
I love
make poetry cool again
um I couldn't agree more poetry used to
be like just like a fun thing people did
like now I feel like people just like
sit on their phones all day but people
used to like sit around and write poetry
all day no and really think to yourself
when was the last time I sat down and
wrote a haiku
I can say personally it was about two
months ago when I did this box but I
don't know what you could say
I was probably going to say the last
time I wrote a haiku was when I learned
what a haiku was in Middle School and we
had to like write a fake one
yeah
that's a little bit about so unfortunate
so toast holiday packs are here get
yours that way you can celebrate the
holidays with us even though today is
our second to last show which is a
little misleading because there's going
to be so much content on patreon I think
you guys are literally gonna be like go
away we don't right like we want to miss
you I am headed down to Florida today so
for honestly I didn't even book a return
flight so we're gonna Bank all of our
patreon content instead of releasing it
earlier in the month we're gonna do it
later in the month when there is no
toast so if you guys are missing us you
can always go to patreon.com because we
are thoughtful we're also business women
but we're also thoughtful business women
we are thoughtful business women that's
who I want to be
um you know who I want to be Selena
Gomez please tell us about your
afternoon yesterday let me tell you how
I was just not expecting like what I
really had no idea of like what this
event was and it was so cool so rare
Beauty they just launched a spring
collection new highlighters and I walked
in of course I was late it was not his
latest counselor but it was just the
traffic in the city people love New York
in the city and I've actually really
started to love New York again and now
I'm starting to hate it again like good
luck getting anywhere you said people
love New York in the city I think you
meant in the holidays sorry during the
holidays it's like this magical time and
when you walk down Fifth Avenue at night
with the lights like it is it is really
magical but it's becoming my least
favorite place in the world like I have
to get out of here it's so Progressive
the traffic is so congested there's so
many people like tourists it's just not
to gatekeep but like get the [ __ ] out no
I came to New York during the holidays
to see all these lights and I forgot
about holiday traffic and holiday
traffic is the reason I moved I was like
what am I doing here it took us an hour
to get to dinner one night an hour to
get dinner it's foot traffic too like
it's just so congested it's like I gotta
get here
um so I was late of course and I walk in
and I was just not expecting how small
this event went it was it was maybe 15
influencers Selena and her team maybe 20
influencers and they were really like
top tier makeup girly so honestly I was
not entirely sure what I was doing there
but I know that it was a super like
enormous honor to have been invited so I
was just like going along with it and
then the longer I spent there the longer
I realized that I was solely invited
because everyone who works for Selena
Gomez is a toaster they were so nice
they were like oh my God Jax price
clutch Trice McLaren like they knew all
the lingo they were so nice like and
that's why I actually understood because
really the success of rare beauty is
unprecedented they're really the biggest
makeup brand right now it's insane like
they're up there with Fenty Beauty and
they're so much newer and now I know
it's because everyone who works there is
a toaster so they're obviously like
really smart people who have it going on
hard-working Queens does that make sense
yeah no further explanation needed so
Selena just basically sat with all of us
and gave us two like tutorials on all
the new products and she was so so funny
and so pretty and then we all got to
spend time with her individually they
would just bring us into a separate room
you can make content with Selena just
talk with her and me and Margo went in
together and I just have to say it
almost felt unfair to be able to like be
attending with my sister like Margaret
wasn't my plus one Margaret was invited
on her own as an influencer
um and those events can be awkward and
when you can't bring a plus one like you
really have to like be very social and
like it's it's awkward so I felt like I
cheated the system a little bit because
I literally walked in with my sister and
it's just like not fair
um and we also got to do the Celine
thing together so we got like a lot of
time with Selena because it was like two
people in one you know
um she was
I actually like was thinking about her
the whole day she was amazing like she
was so normal like so normal so nice so
open like so everyone got to film
content with her and I had the idea to
do like my series where I try new foods
if she would help me you know get
through trying an olive and I was like
fully prepared for her to say no I was
like it's totally fine if you say no
like I won't be offended she was like no
let's do it I love olives she was so
cool and so nice and like I really felt
like the version of her I know from like
social media and like in just media in
general and then her documentary I was
so Overjoyed to see like in real life
she's like a very happy
cool nice normal person and of course
she was probably like you know you're
working when you put on like your work
face but I could tell like she was
really very fulfilled by her work and it
was amazing it was really one of the
coolest events I've ever been invited to
I was really grateful to have been
invited my content is trending we're
going fine oh my God I was like I knew
that you were gonna like that when I was
first watching her video I was like okay
so she did her series with Selena and
let's watch by the end I was cackling
thanks Selena thanks Selena and I did
slip in a Selena I know I have to be me
you know
yeah no she didn't seem face and now
knowing what we know about her like I'm
sure that she takes the Selena and
stride 100 uh but I'm so glad to hear it
was such a great day and she's doing so
well and that she's so happy because
like we saw in the documentary those
days where she's doing like press stuff
and working like she like hated those
days but maybe because it's like rare
beauty stuff she loves us yeah and she's
not talking to like those interviewers
who ask her like invasive personal or
stupid questions she's talking like real
girls just like her totally and she it I
really felt like she did her research on
everyone in the room she was like oh man
I love your content like she really she
was just really amazing and the rare
beauty team we all went home with like
PR boxes of the whole collection which
I'm so excited for because it's all sold
out but in the campaign for the shoot
which Selena looks so sickening in she's
wearing these retro feet earrings that
are big dangly earrings that say S and G
and everybody got to go home with a pair
of earrings with their own initials on
them which is like such a thoughtful
gift and like these earrings are
expensive and like I love retrofit and I
was like wow what what a gift
that's so cool do you like are you upset
that now that we wear these headphones
you can't really wear earrings on the
show yes
because you're a big earring girl so
when I went to the event yesterday right
after the toast Margo read me to [ __ ]
filth she's like why aren't you wearing
earrings I was like Jesus Jesus and I
was like I just got here okay
um I'm not wearing earrings because I
have to work you know maybe if you had a
job that you were passionate about you
would know what it's like but you don't
but she does but she has two
um but wait so then
it was so cool because everyone I had
figured she was going to be there I
don't know if you know let me explain to
you what an Alex Earl is
I know a little bit but tell me more so
she's this tick tocker who I swear like
I'm sure she's been on the platform for
a while but she blew up in the last like
three weeks I think she's over a million
followers now it's she reminds me a lot
of Emily Mariko who just like kind of
came out of nowhere top of their game
everyone was like for no actual reason
just obsessed with this one person
um but Emily Mariko does cooking and
Alex Earl does makeup and she just sits
she's like a University of Miami college
student she's like this really pretty
fun girl
um who sits in her house and does makeup
and everyone has become obsessed with
her and everyone's like more than people
being like have you met Selena Gomez
they were like did you meet Alex Earl so
I did meet her she was so nice and I had
like so many questions for her because
you know I think for us and just like
for me in this line of work like it's
very much been like a slow burn there
wasn't like one moment where I woke up
one day and like everything was
different so I was just like asking her
all these questions I was just like what
is your life like is it so crazy how
like a month ago you were just
completely normal and now you're getting
you know paid to travel the world and a
million people know who you are and she
like really could not put into words
what it was like she was like it's so
crazy and she had all these questions
for like me and I was also Lauren wolf
was there who's been tick talking for a
while and she was just like so new to
the influencer space and she was like
what do you guys do with all these PR
boxes and I was like that's such a good
question I really still don't know I
know like I still don't know like I used
to give everything to my sisters and
then you guys were like all right we
have enough stuff now I give a lot of it
to um like people that work in my
building like different like Porters or
housekeepers
um I keep some stuff but I donated most
of it like she was like I don't know
what to do I live in a house with six
girls and like there's so many boxes I'm
like well that's ideal you in a house
with six girls like you got a [ __ ] ton
of makeup take some for yourself and
then share with she's like I think
they've had enough like I don't know
what to do with and I imagine for her
like she's getting inundated yeah with
PR
um so it's just so cool to like talk to
someone who's like on the precipice of
like super stardom and it was so normal
and so nice
that's so awesome it was really it was
fabulous but I got home I was exhausted
because you know I don't have like a
large social battery and it was just
like a lot of talking and like you know
for me like I have to be like loud and
funny I just can't be normal like I have
some sort of disease
um but it was a fabulous day like thank
you so much to all the rare Beauty girls
who invited me I would love to be
invited again it was so fun
does Alex still go to school yes I
actually asked her I was like are you
gonna like finish
your degree and she was like I graduated
in May I'm like you know barely hanging
I'm barely hanging on but I'm gonna
continue yeah yeah I was gonna ask what
year is she but if she's seen her she's
a senior she's about to graduate and
she's just having like you know so many
opportunities like travel for a week and
I'm sure make a lot of money and it's
like how do you balance something like
that with like what you're told you
should do which is like graduate college
you know yeah I think if she was earlier
in her college Years but like
she's so close the money is spent I was
trying not to be like an old sage
no I think that's good but I was like
Claudia you were offended when I said it
no yesterday I was definitely being like
a maternal figure to everyone you were
being an influencer Mentor well because
I said like for me when I graduated
college too the same thing was happening
to me like I was being offered like
trips and and money and I was like how
do I prioritize school when school was
costing me money and torturing me and my
work is actually making me money and
fulfilling me and I'm getting all these
opportunities and I was just like just
do the bare minimum just do the bare
minimum get through it just get your
degree I think she had planned to do
maybe some sort of like after you know
higher education beyond that I don't
know if she's still going to do that but
she was really cool and she's smart
she's got it going on she's she's going
to have a big career ahead of her
that's awesome well she could always do
more school right that's what I said
it was um it was a fabulous afternoon
and then I had my book club so I'm here
I'm feeling very fulfilled
how was your book club
amazing but clubs can be so fulfilling
amazing you know we it's only our second
meeting and we had we had some notes for
each other on how to you know Advance
the book club because you know when you
get together with your friends all you
want to do is like sit there and gossip
right so what are the notes we have to
like we we actually we actually let me
say it again we actually
no dig you actually though but we really
do actually talk about the redheads so
much at our book club because like it's
really for like Abe listens like it's
really for a lot of us the only book
club we've ever like heard of
so we're like well what do they do with
the redheads and we were thinking about
choosing a book and they were like well
what did the redheads choose like it's
you were really following in your
footsteps for when it comes to book club
and we've decided like some certain
points we want to do like you know the
online book cup Club questions from the
author or from whatever we also want to
do Hollywood treatment because everyone
like loves to share but we like could
like as we were leaving we were like oh
I wouldn't do Hollywood treatment so we
sat back down so we just need to
organize a little bit got it got it that
makes sense yeah and they come with
questions that's great yeah and I do
feel like
from what I've heard there are other
book clubs around the country that
either like read the redheads books and
like they might be like toasters who are
like we're gonna start again so then
we're gonna follow the redheads and
we'll talk about it
I think the redheads are just like you
know inspiring book clubs across the
world and for me like even if you don't
read let me tell you the value in a book
club at least my book club it's once a
month guaranteed for me a kosher
home-cooked meal I had such a [ __ ]
Feast last night and then the time
before I had like literally roast
chicken my friends love to cook last
night I had kosher hamburgers and
schnitzel like it was a feast Beyond we
were just like eating the whole time
laughing it's really and on the way home
we were all like looking at each other
we were like this is nice we were like
we really need to continue this it's a
great way to keep in in touch with your
friends but it's also just like
uh for me at least like I read such like
dumb books and my book club books are
like a little bit more elevated and it's
nice that like once a month I'll read
like a real book
yeah it's really good clean fun it's
good clean fun we are hoping to maybe do
one on like a Friday or Saturday night
so we can get like lit maybe a Thursday
um but we'll see
you can get literary
literally
what's your next book
well the other thing I can't stop
talking about at the book club is you
because I'm like everything I know about
books I know from you and everything I
know about book clubs I know from you
you're in like three so I'm like well
Jackie says this book sucks and I Don't
Know Jack didn't like that book and we
almost picked portrait of a mirror okay
I love that book that I remember you
just talking about and
I read the description I was like oh my
God this [ __ ] sounds terrible and
then you told me I wouldn't like it so
we didn't choose it but the whole time I
just don't think you like the writing I
don't think you would like the writing I
think it's so dense I think Abe might
like it I actually think some of your
friends might like it but it will take
you a really long time to read and
you're gonna be like and it's less so
about the plot there is some plot that's
interesting and I love the way that it
ends but it's it's more like character
interesting people I basically role play
at my book club as you I'm like well
Jackie doesn't think that we should do
that
that's so funny they're probably like
this girl and her [ __ ] sister no
that's the other thing one more time I
think everyone in my book club really
respects you as the book influencer that
you are like they respect your opinion
and it's it's very nice
wow that's so sweet no it's really sweet
you're kind of like Making Waves
I'm Making Waves in the book world I
think
and I love it you love to see it
how's world
he's great he's so excited to see you no
because the way I'm not ready honestly
I'm obviously excited to see rolled
um but I did just see him a week ago and
I haven't seen Kaylor in like three
months like the way I will tackle her
and she's just gonna have to put up with
it like I've been watching so much K
video I actually saw a video of Kayla
singing the ABCs in Hebrew and she
stopped at like hey but still like
it was it was almost too much for me
that is too much well she is sturdy
enough to tackle you know now that she's
big like there's no stopping me like I'm
such a physical lover like not I'm a
very physical and I'm like an aggressive
person like I just want to smell other
people and kisses and the hard part
about being an aunt is like you actually
can't do that with kids up until a
certain age because they're quite
fragile you know but Kayla is you know
she's indestructible now and I'm going
to literally put on a helmet and run
straight towards her and just tackle her
to the ground and she's just gonna have
to deal with it she's just gonna have to
figure it out she's gonna love it I
think so too
so exciting well the sooner we get on
with the show the sooner you can get on
your flight yeah oh my God
also today we are recording such an
exciting interview like yeah to be
secret project annoying it will come out
tomorrow we just don't like to say until
it drops you just never know someone's
scheduled to change and then we're just
a bunch of lying things like lunches
things happen all the time so
let's get into the fast five stories
that you need to know yes you McLarty
actually they're the stories that I need
to know because once again we're wife
swapping yeah now and once again I do
feel the need to make a disclaimer I'm
still new at this
okay so be kind well who was mean to you
Noah no one I'll kill him no nobody was
me no no no like absolutely nobody
um so I just want to say when it comes
to stories there's no breaking celeb
news there's like some moronic celebrity
stuff some updates to stuff we already
have spoken about but then there's one
story that I'm gonna lead with which is
like some major
Tick Tock slash HIPAA drama that's gosh
what HIPAA oh is this the nurses yes
yeah I want to talk about that so I will
explain to you if you don't know and
I'll explain to everyone listening what
is going on in the labor and delivery
nurse drama yeah okay great can't wait
also like let's get real if you're
coming to the show for the stories
why this is the thing Jackie when you
become a toaster when you come for the
stories but you stay for the girlies
yeah like you're here for the girlies
like who knows what could happen the
stories are just a vessel a vessel for
us to continue talking about ourselves
and the things that interest us like
this isn't a breaking news show no this
isn't like really the pop culture hour I
wouldn't say so no I would say like when
there's something like major going on
like we're gonna break it down till the
last drop yeah but in between I don't
know day to day we're just here to be
your friends
someone posted a tick tock that you
reposted that said like I'm so glad that
these sisters recorded their FaceTime
call and posted on the internet every
day and like that's literally what this
is also I did have to dodge like every
single Megan and Harry story because so
annoying like the doc comes out at
midnight and then paycheck says 15
articles about everything you need to
know and I don't want to spoil it we're
going to try and watch it today before
I'm desperate to watch it today because
I want to finish the recap before the
end of the week if we don't happen to be
able to watch it today we'll recap it on
patreon but I I'm gonna try my best but
I also have so many things to do have to
pack have to interview I'm going out
tonight the [ __ ] are you packing for I'm
coming to you oh you're going on
vacation trip right right yeah
sorry so I forgot
uh I remember that without further I'm
going on vacation
I am going on vacation
vacations All I Ever Wanted honestly you
ever heard that song like Isme
maintenance all I've ever wanted I know
reincarnation is not a Jewish thing I
know but I struggle with that too I'm
obsessed with the concept and it makes a
lot of sense to me Jackie I struggle
with that too
so I think that you are a reincarnated
member of the ghost because vacation
have to get away I have to get away
yeah
you're also like Henry the eighth's
little brother
sure do you remember that joke yes
because the joke is that I don't
remember
I don't even know what you're talking
about honestly like I just know that
they're choke I forget why we just said
that you are like Henry the eighth's
stubborn little we were doing a patreon
episode famous couples throughout
history yeah and something about Henry
the eighth
I don't honestly I don't even remember
the origin of the joke that's like a
toast joke that's so deep even I don't
remember it
even I don't remember the origin right
that's when you know it's lost that's
when you know we've hit a low we have
too many jokes no no I mean like you
have to make room for other jokes and
Other Stories 100
otherwise you're just living in the past
100
okay now let's get into the past five
stories that Claudia thinks that you
need to know today and those stories
that Claudia thinks that you need to
know are brought to you by seed you guys
let's talk about seed let's get real it
turns out everything you think you know
about probiotics might be wrong yeah
probiotic tortilla trips are probably
too good to be true so what is seed it's
a daily symbiotic a broad spectrum
two-in-one probiotic and Prebiotic it is
a 24 strain broad spectrum probiotic and
Prebiotic formulated for Digestive gut
immune and additional systemic benefits
the capsule is actually in another
capsule so that when you swallow it it
protects against stomach acid digestion
enzymes and bile salts for viability
through digestion so that that inner
capsule will make it all the way where
it needs to go so that in layman's terms
you can make a big soft Duty okay and
here at the toast we are trying to get
you we're BSD friendly and anything
that's going to help you move your
bowels is something that we feel really
really passionate about okay
so start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com toast and use code toast to
redeem twenty percent off your first
month of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic
that's seed.com toast and nude code
toast so seeds ds01 daily symbiotic is
what you need to help you support
digestion and get your gut in check if
seed supports benefits in and Beyond the
gut and it will support ease of bloating
Health irregularity and ease of
evacuation ease of evacuation is a much
nicer way of saying comfortable Duty
I'm going to leave it at that BSD a nice
big one okay thanks seed also today's
episode is brought to you by solo studio
so once your bowels are right and tight
head outside with your solo stove you
guys solo stove is the greatest
invention ever because whether you're a
city dweller and you have a balcony or
an outdoor space or you live in the
suburbs you want to get a solo stove
because there's nothing quite like the
feeling of gathering around a warm fire
on a cool evening and a smokeless fire
pit from solo stove makes your outdoor
moments even more memorable we love a
fire pit moment and when Claudia isn't
you know singing off her eyelashes and
her baby hairs but that did not happen
with the solo stove and she had been
using a solo maybe if you had a solo
stove that wouldn't have happened to you
so we're going to create some great
family memories this weekend when some
of the fam is getting together at my
house where I have a solo stove that I
love so dearly it's a great place to
make memories and stay cozy because yeah
it is getting a little chilly here let
the gifting begin oh yeah an amazing
gift not a stocking stuffer it's a
little big but little big you can chop
stole the stove's holiday event sale for
huge site-wide savings and get 10 off
with promo code toast plus a lifetime
warranty and free 30-day returns get an
extra 10 off holiday deals at
sobosove.com promo code toast not only
is it a smokeless fire pit it is so easy
to use you can move it around you can
take it with you we've been on road
trips where we pack up that solo stove
and we take it to where we're heading
next also an amazing gift idea for an
outdoor person or an indoor person who
wants to get a little more comfortable
outside just saying so let's get
comfortable seeing uncomfortable
but so with solo so honestly like you're
a princess
a princess
[Laughter]
break
he's running I think like there's
nothing more unattractive than having to
snot up your nose I'm like so
like hopefully our cameras are like not
that high good of a quality that anyone
could see this yeah I've entered the
phase of like I don't need to blow my
nose it's just trickling a little it's
honestly like uglier
agreed except I blow my nose like a fog
horn so oh speaking of ugly I during
Selena's like presentation yesterday I
made a joke oh you told me you made a
little joke you think you made Selena
laugh I made Selena laugh okay so not
only did I make the whole room laugh
like I made Selena laugh it was just
like this iconic moment where she was
like you know when you're someone
searching for a word and like you want
to help them I do it all the time and I
have to stop doing it because I'm always
giving I do it all the time and I don't
even give them a minute to like think
about the word so Selena was saying how
her new highlight is baked and it's not
going to give you like crazy coverage
because she hates that look where you
just put on highlighter and she kept
like touching her face and you get that
like
and she could she was like what's the
word and she looked at me and I was like
strobe she was like yes it's so
and I was like
ugly
and she was like I don't know if she was
just being nice but she thought I was
hilarious
I think she
thinks you're funny I think she thinks
I'm funny too that should be your
Instagram bio Selena thinks I'm funny
made Selena laugh and then put the date
oh my God and the salinators will follow
you
the salinators actually came for Margo I
saw Margo we were all like scrambling
I'm not happy I'm just I just think it's
[ __ ] nuts
because you were like I saw yeah yeah
get her
so we were all like scrambling for what
to do that was me smiling being like
salinators need help they need help
Margo was like I'm gonna ask Selena what
her favorite Midnight song is
um and I thought that was like an
amazing idea I don't know why people are
coming for Margo but people are like wow
you get in a room with Selena and you
ask her about another person
it's like it's called making
conversation no and also it's like
celebrities don't need to talk about
themselves all the time and like people
shouldn't talk about themselves all the
time yeah Selena what are your interests
Selena what was your Spotify rap like
Selena let's talk about like the things
that you like not just like Selena all
the time I'm sure that Selena doesn't
want no one wants to talk about
themselves like that much before seven
so true
okay so our first story is from the cut
and it's a little deep dive and an
update on those maternity nurses
um who did the viral ick tick tock okay
so share the Deets yeah then I have
questions
Atlanta Emery's University hospital
midtown is facing backlash after a
Tick-Tock video of four nurses sharing
their icks regarding labor and delivery
patients went viral for all the wrong
reasons so one of them said my ick is
when you ask me how much the baby weighs
and the baby is still in your hands one
nurse says in the video it's a play on
The Tick Tock Trend that typically
involves people sharing pet peeves about
dating my ick is when you come in for
your induction talking about can I
shower and eat that's what another nurse
said another says that her ich is when
patients say they don't want any pain
medicine no epidural but you are at an 8
out of 10 pain the list goes on with the
nurses noting their frustrations with
their patients
and the partners of patients and their
families as well the original video has
since been deleted but not before copies
made the rounds on social media the
nurse's comments felt especially cruel
given that in addition to being
traumatic for many women childbirth is
already painful it's costly and it's
incredibly risky particularly in the U.S
where women regularly deal with severe
complications of pregnancy over
childbirth in a statement posted to its
Instagram page the hospital referred to
the nurses as quote former employees and
said that the comments they made about
maternity patients in the video were
disrespectful and unprofessional The
Washington Post reports that Emory did
not respond to a request for
clarification about whether the nurses
were fired or if they chose to leave
their jobs in the comments of the Emory
Hospital post several women were called
their own negative experiences giving
birth at that hospital in addition to
calling out the nurses for an absence of
empathy for their patients and their
General lack of professionalism many
commenters criticize the hospital itself
saying quote they learned to have that
attitude because you helped facilitate
that one person wrote adding that Emery
should take this opportunity to truly do
better for birthing mothers
um so this video made the rounds people
were like immediately like what the [ __ ]
but the vote the video had went so viral
so quickly that deleting it was just
like a lost cause they might as well
have left it up because they were you
know people were saving it screen
recording it
um and it really bothered a lot of
people so much so that like it became
This Global story and the nurses were
fired or left I guess Emory not
clarifying on that makes me well because
if I was about to give birth at Emory
and I saw one of those women walk in I'd
say get the [ __ ] out of here no I mean
there is this like culture on
Tick Tock where nurses make a lot of
content
at work
and it definitely feels off
to put it lightly right like yeah
I think there are this is by far the
most egregious thing I've seen I also
don't see a lot of it
um
because I'm not on Tick Tock so it has
to like reach a level where it's meeting
likes me I saw it a few days ago because
New York Post had like posted on their
Instagram like the story and I actually
so I clicked it because I was at first I
was like what the [ __ ] and when you
think about like childbirth and like
everything that you go do you know what
technically there's a lot of icks right
so like what's what are they saying
because it's so you have to be so
vulnerable to like literally spread your
legs and let at all concerns go away 100
put yourself trust in this person and
just do your thing so I'm like what are
they saying and then I saw they didn't
have a good Roundup of what the icks
were and only one that I really
understood was like when you're the
baby's father and you have two women
giving birth in rooms next to each other
and you're like running
to both rooms
oh like one man having two children on
the same day does that happen a lot no I
don't know but like the exact same
moment of the exact same day I was like
yeah that's that's kind of crazy okay
still but now you describing like ick
like I want to know how much my baby
weighs when he's on my chest like that's
not how is that icky like that's how we
measure how big a baby is like I don't
know what what weight I'm holding is
this a big baby that I'm holding is this
a small baby I guess they're trying to
say like I don't know how much a baby
weighs he's on your chest but it's like
oh sorry I just came back take the baby
first
whatever sorry this person just gave
birth to a human being and they want to
know how much he weighs and they're not
thinking about you right and then what
was the other one oh they come in for an
induction they want to eat and shower
so okay like it's just so heartless no
and it's really it's deplorable it's
deplorable like I I mean I'm never gonna
be like you know burn them at the stake
but like if that's how you feel about
your job you shouldn't be working there
no especially it's one thing to like you
know think it maybe have a girls night
out with your fellow nurses and talk
about some frustrations of the day to
put that [ __ ] on social media in your I
think they filmed it in the hospital in
their scrubs like
goodbye yeah
goodbye goodbye goodbye good baby bye I
never saw the whole video though but uh
I'm now getting like bits and pieces of
the story honestly I don't want to see
the whole video because that makes you
feel so self-conscious shameful
shameful that's not the kind of shame we
need to be bringing back we don't need
to be shaming birthing mothers no you're
right that's who doesn't need shame I
think in order to like really like give
in to the process of giving birth like
you can't be thinking like oh I wonder
if this nurse thinks I'm like looking
ugly like and I think this Tick Tock
like maybe could confirm for someone
who's like really paranoid like oh my
God they do think that yeah of course
like I remember when I was giving birth
like it's not super common it's the
whole time I'm like oh my God I'm sorry
like I'm sorry like and like also
something when you're first in pain like
before I got the epidural like I was
just like Nightmare and then afterwards
I'm like I'm so sorry but it's not me
and
um
and like to know they're just like
harboring all of it and judging you I'll
give birth at home next time 100 I do
have to say I don't think it's fair to
paint with a broad brush like I think
most nurses are probably like really
what you think they are like don't worry
sweetie we see this all the time and
like they know that it's part of their
job but to know that there are people
out there who not only like really
genuinely think that but then would feel
comfortable enough sharing it on a major
public platform is so disheartening
so disheartening so let's talk about the
nurses on Tick Tock that you alluded to
yeah I think I feel like they're
literally always joking about this on
SNL and I actually was just watching a
clip online from Tim Dillon's special
and it was like the joke was like and I
just want to say before I'm not coming
for the nurses we have so many nurse
toasters and we and I have so much for
nurses I think it's the most amazing job
I think in order to be a nurse like you
really have to be a special type of
person and I have to say all of my
experiences with nurses in my life
though uh there haven't been that many
but like giving birth was the the
biggest one I had the most amazing and
they switched like every six hours and
it's like it's so sad we just got to
know each other but then the new one
comes it's like you're incredible too
yeah so this is this is so nice I've
only had the most wonderful experiences
like things I've seen online like in any
job there are terrible people who are
nurses but that doesn't mean all nurses
are terrible like nurses for the most
part are amazing people but it's a joke
that Tim Dylan had made was like we
never should have started calling nurses
Heroes because the next thing you know
they're renegading in front of a dead
body
yeah and it is this Tick-Tock culture
when it comes to the nursing industry
where it feels like of course anyone can
make a tick tock but like I think if
you're a nurse making a tick tock you
should make it at home
agreed also I think when nurses were
like making dances in the height of the
pandemic like At first I was like oh
like some relief and cuteness from the
nurses they're going they're putting
everything on their back but then when
you think about it it's like it took me
a like a cumulatively a number of hours
to learn the Renegade and we're being
told that our hospitals are overrun and
there's no sleep and it's like how'd you
all learn the keys no no it's a very
fair question
um
so I feel like I think a general rule of
thumb should be no no
sorry I can't talk no tick-tocking on
the clock
don't talk on the clock
speed goes up tonight and I think that
probably might should be the case like
for a lot of jobs agreed I see some jobs
I'm like don't you have a job to do well
there's this oh man that's so funny
there's this other unless it's something
where it's like some people are recorded
24 7 in their job so like the content
right there and there was like they
posted
like no but there's this like
tick-tocking Duo I love them it's this
Father and Son contractor they like have
a construction company and they're like
in the middle of building a house and
they're making like these and they're
both really good dancers and people in
the comments are like oh this is why my
house is delayed like it is like a
little bit of a weird thing right like
on its face you're telling me they're
dancing and they're Contracting fathers
unduo I'm like oh that's cute and then
it's like
but you're on the clock and there's a
house to build and now you're like
jumping on the foundation right unless
like your job like if you work in media
and like you're making tick tocks like
you know breaking news
hostages like that's different I don't
know actually certain jobs like
I don't know
yeah it's I'd say that's an ick
oh yeah no they said that pissed me off
I do think that Emery like the hospital
should clarify whether or not they were
fired or left on their own accord
because honestly if I was like a
birthing mother in Atlanta and I saw the
star yet like I would and I had to
choose like should I go to Emory or the
one down the road I'd probably just go
to the one down the road
but sometimes like people resign when
they're about to get fired uh-huh so
it's like they didn't get fired they
resigned but they would have been fired
if they didn't yeah so
not in the hospital getting canceled
that's something I never thought I'd say
yeah
crazy
um so our next story is an update to a
story we spoke about earlier in the week
it was Katie Holmes's atrocious outfit
her stylist is defending the
controversial dress over Jean's Jingle
Ball outfit okay so it wasn't a mistake
no
so the Dawson's Creek Alum practically
broke the internet when she paired what
many assumed was a blue satin mini dress
over a pair of jeans at the Jingle Ball
2022 but it turns out that piece was
actually a top so her stylist Brie Welsh
explained the thought process behind her
viral look sharing that they wanted to
give up a more youthful feel for Jingle
Ball and the atmosphere there atmosphere
there the Celeb stylist said that her
client
her client's early ought style which
featured a blue satin bustier top from a
brand called Tov and Reformation Wilder
YG leggings and Mesa margella sneakers
leggings
sorry jeans sorry did I say leggings
yeah I'm literally not okay oh I thought
the stylist was like trying to Gaslight
us no sorry wide leg jeans got it
um it was an attempt to mix casual and
dressy items here's what she said we
decided the rich color and subtle
bustier effect detailing of the top was
elegant and would be fun if paired with
jeans the decision to wear kicks was
down to Katie herself with Welsh
revealing on the day of and because
Katie has her own effortless style that
should be appreciated here she said she
wanted to wear sneakers because it was a
concert and obviously there would be a
lot of dancing to do a Lipa adding
nothing is more comfortable than
sneakers the stylus also shared
um uh on her Instagram story she shared
the article that she did the interview
with in the New York Times and shared in
all caps and wrote and it's a top so she
didn't like that people were assuming
that this was a mini dress I guess it
was like a really low top that's not the
problem right my gripe is not with it
being a dress it's with it being fugly
right and my gripe is not with the top
whatsoever I don't need Clarity on the
top my my gripe is with the cut of the
pants and the shoe the color of the the
top is actually pretty cute if she had
worn it with
tights like really even black leggings
yeah something these jeans like I feel
like rip from Yellowstone would wear
these jeans yeah and the shoes were
terrible
yeah so don't like now try and like
distract us with the top because it was
never about it's never about the top no
top is fine
yeah
I feel like the top is something they
would have worn on Laguna Beach back in
the day
yeah or even like now honestly I would
wear that top it's fine
it's not my pants no the pants are
Reformation like Reformation do better
should be ashamed it's shameful this
[ __ ] issue a statement 100 they should
they oh it's all an apology
yeah they do so nice cover up Katie
Holmes's stylist but we're not buying
what you're selling
now we ain't
um a little a little uh crypto news
what's going on SPF
what do you do now so you know he was
arrested finally
and his family is reportedly calling the
prison to request vegan meals for him
so the disgraced crypto billionaire Sam
bakeman Freed's relatives are reportedly
calling the rodent infested Bahamas
prison where he is being held and asking
if he could get vegan meals the founder
of the collapsed cryptocurrency exchange
FTX who was charged this week with
multiple Financial crimes has his own
room in the maximum security section of
the Bahamas lockup that is known to be
crawling with rats and maggots unnamed
sources told Bloomberg but bankman
Freed's relatives called The Fox Hill
jail in Nassau on Tuesday night to
request that vegan meals be provided to
him a source told the outlet the 30 year
old bankman freed who was known in
crypto by his initials SBF was ordered
earlier Tuesday to remain at the
notorious jail through February 8th for
his extradition hearing he was arrested
this week on multiple charges stemming
from allegations that he received he
deceived FTX customers and investors to
enrich himself and others he can't
receive any visitors due to covid-19
restrictions at the jail a site which a
warden once described as not fit for
Humanity
damn I didn't realize where he was sent
was like this forlorn facility no and
like given that it's so horrible I would
imagine there's a lot of other requests
that they should make before vegan meals
yeah it's like why is that a priority
I don't know that's actually like kind
of sad even though he is like totally
like a criminal like you like that's
inhumane
I didn't know the Bahamas was home to
like this well-known like crazy ass
prison yeah but I guess that's also a
risk you run when you fly there no when
you commit crimes there no but like he
went there he could have been in the U.S
and been arrested here and gone to a U.S
prison but he ran to the Bahamas and so
that's a risk that you run that you will
end up in a Bahamian jail but I also
think a lot of his crimes were committed
because when we broke down if you but he
had his like Penthouse in Albany Bahamas
not Albany New York which is confusing
if you don't know anything about this
guy or like his cribes we did break it
down on the patreon it's the
Thanksgiving episode
um and I think what we from our
understanding of his crimes is like he
spent a lot of time committing those
crimes in the Bahamas so I don't know if
he'll also be prosecuted
in the Bahamas
I don't know but he's being charged by
the U.S and he's being extradited right
which is like like when you flee to
another country and then they bring your
ass back right so I guess the Bahamas is
like no we got him we got you guys we'll
spend a few months here and then we'll
send him back
yeah this is like the craziest story not
the vegan part just like I know but like
so many people lost all of their money I
know just regular people I know like
everybody's like talking about the
celebrity Factor but like who cares this
is the way when we spoke about on the
patreon I didn't like understand what
the matter what his thing was but like
for me to understand it was basically as
if like Robin Hood
just got wiped out and all the money
that you had in there
was gone so some people like might have
been investing like with all of their
savings like and some people lost
everything like people who are unlike
Sam SBF and his friends who can't afford
to lose their their savings and every
celebrity and every like major
institution that aligned themselves with
FTX made it
made a regular people think it was okay
it legitimized FTX being like oh this is
a safe place to invest some of my
savings so like there's a responsibility
on them too but like I don't feel bad
for those people who put money like
you're no I don't feel bad for those
people but I feel bad for the everyday
people and like and so if SPF doesn't
have his vegan meal like can't catch me
caring I'll be totally fine I will go on
with my day just splendidly yeah also
sometimes jails can be like
accommodating with dietary restrictions
you know for like a religious religion
or something but to be a vegan like
aren't you embarrassed not in general
but like you're in uh like jail you've
committed a horrible horrible crime that
affects so many people and like you're
worried about your vegan meal no it's
true so it's like you care about animals
but you don't care about human beings
right no that's true and like in prison
I feel like um there's there's like a
moral hierarchy in prison that I find
really interesting and I feel like in
prison they actually like respect
religion you know like
prayer and like if you wanted like a
teacher or a Halal meal
um but I feel like they don't respect
veganism
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
stick to the meals you know oh there's
actually like I actually didn't choose
it as a story but did you see Taylor
Tomlinson not Taylor Tomlinson that's a
comedian what's her name she plays
Taylor
in High School Musical um
Monique Monique her name is Taylor in
real life I'm sorry she is on Christy
Carlson Romano's podcast talking about
like that for them she went through like
a really dark depression and it was all
kind of like sparked by her not being
invited to do press for High School
Musical 3. it was just
Sharpay Zach Vanessa and Corbin Bleu I
like how I went through like calling
them by their real names and their
character names Sharpay
um and they said there like wasn't room
on the plane for her and Lucas grabiel
and she had like had identified so much
with with Monique and she felt like such
a failure when they didn't invite her
and it like spiraled this really dark
time for it was actually a really good
podcast I listened to like a four minute
clip
yeah I saw that that's so interesting I
was gonna say also like Ryan they were
six some 100 like justice for Ryan like
no and I feel like if they were gonna
cut it down my boy to four
it either should have been of course
Zach and Vanessa but either Sharpay and
Lucas together or Monique and Corbin
together like that why take one from
each couple but let's get real like this
was a multi-billion dollar franchise
like get a bigger plane right High
School Musical 3 was released in
theaters
yeah after two really successful movies
like this is Disney like get the company
jet what did they fly on like a
now what kind of plane can hold four
people but not six well maybe there was
some assistance and you know PR people
still but still a prop engine so she's
making news Monique we love that that's
really sad I know it was like it was
also like so [ __ ] unnecessary like
just get her a ticket
um so SBF is requesting vegan meals and
I just thought everyone absolutely
needed to know that
um I I would agree now are you ready for
our fourth not fourth and final to start
fourth I'm still getting to it I'm still
doing this you guys I'm sorry I'm like
flubbing over my words I'm like
embarrassing everyone I'm so sorry I'm
adding stories about Monique like I'm
still new with this mclarediel you're
doing an amazing job but before you go
on I have to let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by canva you
guys know how passionate you know how
passionate we are about canva and now
we're even more passionate because they
have canva for teams creating visual
content is an essential part of what we
do it's premium content it's things that
we want you guys to share take away
quotes from the show the creative
process so for us has not always been
easy like let's get real ever since we
found Camp up for teams it has been easy
to collaborate and design with our team
which makes the whole process so much
more creative and fun so here are some
templates that are tried and true here
at the toast we just plug them in but
every once in a while Claudia and I will
be like designing whether it's a new
YouTube card for the show or something
that we want to post on Instagram and
even though we are far away from one
another we both go in there and we start
messing with each other's stuff and by
the end of it we have an amazing project
and that's why canva for teams is so
amazing it makes it easy for anyone to
create stunning content in any format
from social media posts to videos
presentations and websites we've never
even made a presentation on canva teams
but like that's a fun project we should
do yeah we just go and like we just
don't need presentations but like let's
make a presentation yeah what if we just
made a presentation yeah with features
designed for brand consistency I think
that's one of the best parts about canva
and canva for teams it makes it easy to
maintain your aesthetic and add your
logos fonts and colors to anything you
create so at the toast we have a lot of
fun we play with color but at the
redheads our aesthetic palette is not to
be messed with and it doesn't ever have
to be messed with because of canva for
teams because everybody has those colors
in the project and that redhead red
garges color of the year
collaborate with canva for teams right
now you can get a free 45-day extended
trial when you go to canva dot me slash
toast that's c-a-n-v-a dot me slash
toast for a 45 Day free extended trial
canva dot me slash toast so I just want
to say if you are working at a job and
you think that your company would be
great with canva like could do really
good things with camera for teams like
you should go to the your boss and be
like let's try canva like you will be
the company star employee of the month
for sure
today's episode is also brought to you
by not to put down any other sponsor but
like one of the tastiest sponsors of all
time Mrs Fields yeah this holiday season
we want to give each person we care
about a gift that will bring them Joy
right yeah now there's one place where
you can find the perfect gift for
everyone on your list Mrs Fields Cookies
who doesn't love fresh from the oven
melt in your mouth cookies I literally I
don't know one person who doesn't love
that neither none not one Mrs Fields has
just what the gift doctor ordered so if
you need a gift idea for lid to really
anyone in your life check out Mrs Fields
it's the perfect gift you can get them
for grandparents parents kids friends
co-workers clients there's something
that will thrill any person any age at
any taste because for over 45 years Mrs
Fields has perfected fresh baked Gourmet
treats we got our Mrs Fields holiday
cookies and not only are they so tasty
but they came in this super cute holiday
unboxing looked like a snow Man Three
Tears you got your brownies you got your
cookies I think there was a Jordan
almond it was really freaking fantastic
so right now Mrs heels is giving the
best deal available only to our podcast
listeners get 25 off everything
site-wide when you go to mrsfields.com
toast that's right Mrs Fields is giving
this exclusive deal only to podcast
listeners 25 off everything at
mrsfields.com toast that's 25 off at Mrs
f-i-e-l-d-s.com slash toast you guys Mrs
Fields is so generous with that discount
code
enjoy
our fourth story is just another update
in the ongoing GMA Saga so Amy roback
and TJ homes are still together amid the
ongoing investigation into their affair
they are trying to make their
relationship work despite the toll that
it has taken on their careers
although the gma3 anchors are at the
center of an internal investigation at
ABC sources have told e-news that they
are very much still together I also did
see people on social media actually
spotting them together out on vacation
on the new couple's romance may be going
strong but sources told the Daily Mail
earlier this week that they have been
trying to keep their distance from one
another because they wouldn't dare be
caught together now not while ABC is
still making a decision The Insider
shared
so as we had stated in order for this to
be okay they have to be together forever
those are jobs they're going to resent
each other and it's not going to work
out there this is what the source says
their marriages are over but they have
children to think about and they don't
want to jeopardize their Futures with
the Network anymore that they already
have so their decision to lay low comes
after ABC News president Kim Godwin
revealed that the pair would be
remaining off of gma3 indefinitely while
the rest of the staff remains upset over
the increased media scrutiny here's what
she said in an email that then page six
stall it is my hope that we will
continue to focus our energy on what we
do best and I want all of you to work to
know how immensely proud I am of your
hard work and professionalism so I guess
there's like a vibe that GMA people are
pissed about but I feel like people are
dumb because this is the best thing that
could possibly happen to an irrelevant
hour of an irrelevant new show
they're so dumb oh they're upset about
media scrutiny like you're a media show
don't you want press don't you want
eyeballs don't you want people to care
about your show this way that the whole
network is handling is they're so dumb
if I was Amy and TJ and they get fired
like they should then get an agent
together and they should pitch their own
show together to ABC to CBS and be like
we're an in love hosting Duo and people
care about what we are doing but like
imagine if you just started like some
extracurricular Affair at work and then
like literally like I don't know what
this real nature of their relationship
is like are they in love or they were
just like [ __ ] around like we're rich
and famous let's just like have sex and
no I think their boyfriend girlfriend
their boyfriend girlfriend they have to
be
because they were going Upstate you
don't go upstate with a [ __ ] buddy
that's true
that's a hotel in the city
yeah so if they come out of this on top
with like you know in love relationship
and like a
either a new job at a different show or
same job but like with way more people
watching and interested in knowing who
you are then I do think they eventually
come out on top of this
I think ABC is making such a big mistake
they've kept people on for who are like
done
but still like it's the same thing still
it's the same thing and
this could be such an opportunity for
them but they're so dumb I know they're
like kind of like dropping the ball
and the people who work there everyone's
talking about our show we're so
distressed oh my God that we put out so
people will talk about our show right oh
no they're not talking about millions of
people not for the reason that we want
but it's the reason that you got oh no
millions of people millions of people
are talking about the show that we want
millions of people to talk about
they're just not saying what we want I
didn't even know there was a third hour
of the GMA show until this like this is
publicity you couldn't even dream of and
yeah it's not great they were both
cheating on their spouses but they're
not criminals okay like it's fine no
crimes were committed nobody was hurt
physically emotionally is another
question
but we'll all be okay
and by the way even if they do like get
let go they'll get let go with these
huge packages they're fine
no but like then they're both not
working and they're looking at each
other like it's your fault yeah it's not
a good Amy's gonna be like you shouldn't
have [ __ ] that producer three years
ago
yeah they're they have they don't have
enough like relationship under their
belt to like withstand that together or
they do and they come out better but I
think that they'll grow resentful if
they both lose their jobs no and then
they have to stay inside to hide from
the paparazzi and they'll just like
literally start to hate each other right
and then they'll break up and then they
don't have their lover and they don't
have their job
and it's not good steak I agree like
this is being grossly mishandled
um so our fifth and final story what is
our fifth and final story I don't
remember what I chose oh it's a little
new TV news that I thought you might
find interesting I did choose this for
you
this new reality show is gonna let you
criticize how other people raise their
kids
so these parents are walking right into
a trap on the new ABC reality series
called the parent test premieres
December 15th families are willingly
taking turns in the hot seat allowing
others to critique their child-rearing
philosophies from helicopter parenting
and high achievement to free range and
child-led across a series of challenges
with small children the world is a
spectator sport everyone's looking to
see if your children are going to behave
the parenting expert Dr Adolf Brown ooh
Adolf that's a tough tough and he just
sinks because he spells it
a-d-o-l-p-h That We're Not Gonna notice
but we notice
um sent to chill he co-hosts the show
with Ali Wentworth and that's what he
told the post so in each episode The Two
Hosts Brown and Wentworth sit in a room
with all the moms and dads each shed of
parents take turns letting the group see
how their children behaved in various
situations such as being encouraged to
jump off a high dive
at a pool going to a fancy restaurant or
responding When a Stranger knocks on
their door then the judging begins every
few episodes the parents vote on which
Styles should Advance forward in the end
one style will emerge Victorious and win
the honor of being deemed the best way
to raise a child there's no cash prize
but the feeling of smugness is priceless
this sounds like the most toxic show on
the planet
yeah and like leave the kids alone like
they're gonna be your little lab rats
like go let them go outside like and
stop like
filming them like what kind of parenting
technique do you obtain child lead
helicopter
I don't I think it's Harry's too young
but I do think I think childhood is nuts
child let us know it's like I definitely
will be a bit of a disciplinarian but I
also have to see how he behaves like if
I have a well-behaved child like I'm not
gonna intervene so much also sometimes
the kid needs to figure out for
themselves but like if I need to like I
will be a strict parent yeah of course
but I don't think already like I'm a
helicopter parent like because I I try
and like give him as much space within
reason I mean he can't walk to figure
stuff out for himself you know like even
if he's like playing like yesterday he's
playing with like my phone stand and
like I didn't see how that could be
harmful harmful so I was like enjoy do
you think that the way you parent
Bruno is at all similar to your
parenting method for children because
I'm like actually really strict with
Theo I let Bruno get away with murder
Bruno could do anything and mommy loves
him and the difference is is that what
Bruno's Behavior you know if he becomes
a spoiled brat like really doesn't
matter Bruno doesn't have to go out into
the world and be that person and be his
own person Bruno doesn't have to you
know be a husband one day and be a
father like it doesn't matter what Bruno
learns to me and I just want Bruno to
learn love and love unconditional love
but when you're raising humans like you
do have to teach them along the way I'm
not teaching Bruno [ __ ] other than go
outside I just got so depressed
why because Bruno's not going to be a
father because Harry's going to get
married to someone
I know I just want to let you know
whoever it is I don't care if it's
literally Queen Elizabeth herself like I
will hate her
I didn't I don't think that I will but
unless she's hateable right which like
oh my God I just like
to me like Harry's always going to be a
baby like he will be a 30 year old man
at some point Who's like looking for a
wife God willing God willing I'm alive
you know I'm I'm gonna make hell for
that girl because if you're gonna
absolutely carry like you you have to
you have to earn it I'm sorry
I'm so jealous of the girl who gets to
marry him like oh my God I'm so upset
I know
it's crazy but anyways Bruno's actions
don't matter really you know that's a
real no but as long as he's a sweet
angel like if he was like crazy and
aggressive like but what so he he gets
into the Cheetos and he wants to eat
Harry's leftovers like do you do your
whisper now but because it doesn't
matter yeah and for Harry like it
matters yeah no I there's like bigger
implications that's fair I was just
wondering if you found yourself like
being a similar sort of Bruno I you I
think you guys see like I'm so leaning
no he could use a little a little uh not
mummies love mummy's angel a little
discipline he's a lover he's not a
fighter you need to be a fighter
not with bro no no yeah he definitely is
your weak spot he is but he's such a
sweet angel and he's a good boy and
that's all that matters no I agree
what about you
I'm like very strict with Theo and Ben
is very blase and I think that's exactly
how it's going to be when we have kids
like I have no problem yelling at
someone because sometimes and I don't
know if this is like a hot take like a
kid needs to be yelled at
yeah oh but I feel like this content on
social media of like parenting and I
literally saw a video last week and it
was like we have to stop telling our
kids to be careful it makes them think
the world is unsafe uh the world is
unsafe and kids need to be careful
look around look around honestly like I
don't want to critique anyone else's
parenting but it was the dumbest thing
I'd ever seen in my life
yeah people are so touchy about
parenting I know I feel like even the
story is going to trigger some people so
let us know what's what's favorite
parenting technique sound off in the
comments let us know what's the worst
parenting advice you've ever heard no
let us know who's the worst parent in
the world
Casey Anthony
um so those were the fast five stories
day two of me choosing the stories let
me know how I did only if you thought I
did a good job if you thought I didn't
do a good job you can literally just go
away and
we'll all be okay and that's our show
correct no TV recap we're gonna do our
best to watch Harry and Megan by
tomorrow but if not we promise there
will be a recap recap over the holidays
on our patreon where we will be posting
content the remainder of December
tomorrow is our last episode of the year
I'm flying to Florida today we will all
be together Bryce Trice McClure and Jax
for the final episode and we actually
have a guests on tomorrow's episode
which is just like a nice added bonus
yeah it's the only person who could make
it on our end of year episode like
seriously it's that [ __ ] premium you
guys I'm being really cool about it but
when you find out who it is you're gonna
be like how is Jackie okay and it's
someone who's never been on the show
before who but who we speak about a lot
and who we really really love and
respect and it's very exciting so we're
actually recording that today and
that'll be on the podcast tomorrow and I
think we'll also do video right
yeah guess who it is in the comments
yeah and let us know if you think she'd
be a good parent okay
have an amazing day thank you guys so
much for listening to the toast the
Monday Morning Show where we deliver the
past five stories you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found on Spotify iTunes Stitcher public
radio guest books all the places we've
listened to
podcasting and
talented we are hope you guys have an
incredib for Thursday and we'll see you
tomorrow for Friday Friday gotta get
down on Friday goodbye and for our last
show of the Year goodbye